dans nos familles seules l'amérique du
titre et des terres votre père a désigné
gonzague
j'aime regarder autour de vous ma tante
le château aurait besoin d'un bon
lifting
pardon abdelkader bensalah
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait la pole mais non
exclusivement d'objets d'art mais c'est
pas encore né et j'ai serré commenté
simple chemise du registre avec quoi
nous ne sommes tout de même pas du même
monde
le pire de tout adam la comtesse il me
tutoie sa santé qu'est ce que vous
faites quand vous êtes énervé il ya un
truc que je fais c'est de la folie genre
de truc ça vous met dans un monde qui
est ce que vous dites et puis parler
français mais c'est tombé ça marchera
pas juste parce que déjà vous allez même
pas arrivé mais de quoi la voûte est
coincé voilà ça dont je vous apprennent
deux trois trucs quand on est bon dans
la vraie vie les gens ils marchent pas
comme ça rigolait vous à la gastro ou
quoi enfin la montée comme serveuse a
lâché les bras on dirait vous portez un
frigo là pour dans leur tête chez les
musiques du pardon tu me vois plus voilà
on ne fera pas une femme tente chaque
été pour dire bonjour j'ai pas compris
moi c'est complètement con votre truc là
on chante tu fais moi j'ai fait ce qui
fait c'est super 15
gg ayant encore besoin d'une formation
cepap allan poe rava non plus faites
vous confiance
il est 9 e le sénégal sont bons ça
qu'elle a l'intention de raser votre
chaton île fabuleuse fille de celui là
va te faire [ __ ] bouffon
tous unis pour la même cause mamba les
goûts écoute moi bien un petit mère de
mes deux tu remontes ton froc
tue-mouches stands et arrête de
mâchonner ce truc là et tu y vas fils un
regard des moyens des mois alors
j'attends ça voilà enfin c'est quand
même plus simple de dire bonjour
[Musique]